Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Hast du gute Laune.
Ja, ich bin fast in Jubelstimmung.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die einhundertdreiundneunzigste Folge dicht
gefolgt auf die äh letzte Sendung, die mal wieder so einen schönen Depressionskatalog zusammengefächert hat und da dachten wir uns äh in der Stimmung wollen wir euch äh nicht alleine lassen und äh wir liefern einfach nochmal was äh Positives ab, denn
äh
es gibt ähm ich weiß noch nicht, ob's was zu feiern gibt, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall erstmal positive Entwicklungen zu berichten. Ja und ihr habt schon gehört, Thomas, Thomas Loninger ist mal wieder da, hallo Thomas.
Guten Morgen.
Äh du bist jetzt gerade in Wien. Wir machen die Sendung mal aus der Ferne, ne.
Und ähm ja, worum kann es schon gehen, äh wenn ich mit dir spreche, es kann eigentlich nur um Netzneutralität gehen und das Thema haben wir ja hier nun schon wirklich sehr oft äh immer wieder auf der Agenda gehabt,
lange begleitet jetzt eigentlich über Jahre, ich glaube drei Jahre
von deinem Wechsel nach Brüssel, deinen Berichten dort äh ähm mit dem ganzen äh Aktivismus, den er betrieben hat mit Edri und anderen Gruppen äh und natürlich jetzt auch jüngst
dem äh vorläufigen Abschluss des ganzen Spaßes nach dem Beschluss der entsprechenden Verordnung zur Netzneutralität,
Und als wir zuletzt gesprochen hatten,
Na ja, da waren die Nachrichten ja nicht so gut, ähm denn die Verordnung war nicht unbedingt im Sinne ähm unserer,
Wie soll ich sagen, bevorzugten Sichtweise, aber du meintest ja, Not-All ist Lost, denn äh da gibt es ja dann noch
Die konkrete Ausgestaltung dieser Verordnung, an der dann letzten Endes eigentlich die ganzen Details hängen und da diese ganze Debatte von Details schwer geprägt war, musste das jetzt eben sozusagen auch noch begleitet und abgewartet werden
Ja und dieser Punkt ist jetzt erreicht und darüber wollten wir,
mal reden, wollte ich mal reden mit dir und freue mich sehr, dass du die Zeit gefunden hast.
Legen wir nochmal los äh mit,
was eigentlich war, also die Netz, die Verordnung zu Netzneutralität ähm in dem Top war ja glaube ich auch noch ein paar andere äh Dinge, Netzneutralität war ein Teil davon.
Eigentlich Roaming war noch das zweite Thema. Die einzigen beiden sind übrig geblieben.
Ja, Roam Roaming war ja auch so ein, so ein bisschen der äh der Wurm, der an der Angel immer vor einem hergetragen wurde, so nach dem Motto, na ja,
macht man das mit der Netzneutralität so, dafür kriegt ihr dann irgendwie kostenlose äh Telefongespräche im Urlaub, was ja auch noch so begrenzt äh erfüllt wurde.
Aber,
Kannst du vielleicht mal darlegen, wie sich die Situation jetzt so in der Summe äh dargestellt hat, nachdem äh,
Kommission, äh also der Triolog sich letztlich mit dem Rat der Europäischen Union, dem Parlament auf ein finales Papier für diese Verordnung äh geeinigt hat.
Genau, also am achtundzwanzigsten Oktober zweitausendfünfzehn gab's die letzte Abstimmung im Europaparlament im großen Plenum,
Und da wurde der Text, den der Trilog, wie du gesagt hast, vorher ausverhandelt hat, angenommen, ohne Änderungsanträge, die wir uns gewünscht hätten.
Damit war ein sehr mehrdeutiges Gesetz in Kraft. Ähm im November wurde das dann äh veröffentlicht und ab dann,
aber klar es braucht noch einen letzten Schritt, weil in dem Gesetz ist angelegt, dass ähm,
neun Monate, nachdem das veröffentlicht wird, äh die europäischen Regulierungsbehörden, Body of European Regulites für Electronic Communications.
Genau auslegen müssen, wie sie dieses Gesetz verstehen. Und deren Auslegung ist deswegen wichtig,
weil die ja für die Umsetzung zuständig sind. Also in Deutschland die Bundesnetzagentur in Österreich, die RTR. Jedes Land hat so einen Telekom-Regulierer und die sind,
Polizei und Richter in einem und ähm bestimmen halt, welche Produkte im Internet erlaubt sind, welche nicht, also was ein Internetprovider tun darf.
Und deswegen ist Dirn Interpretation sehr wichtig, weil die gilt dann, das ist die, die unbesetzt.
In dem Kampf haben wir nochmal alles aufgeboten, was es so gab und am Ende gewonnen. Der Text, der dort jetzt beschlossen wurde,
liefert wirklich den Werkzeugkasten, den wir brauchen, um Netzneutralität in Europa durchzusetzen. Es gibt noch ein paar graue Stellen wie Zero Rating, da sind wir, wie die USA, so, dass wir das Problem aufschieben und nicht wirklich beantworten.
Zum allergrößten Teil die gesamte Zivilgesellschaft zufrieden und feiert und alle Experten sagen ja das ist Netzneutralität ähm.
Das Ganze dann in ein paar Jahren vor Gericht auch so halten wird, werden wir sehen,
aber das ist für heute nicht wichtig, weil wir können jetzt ähm mal endlich beantworten,
schaut's mit der Netzzeutralität in Europa aus, was wird als nächstes passieren, was ist verboten und was ist erlaubt und das ist schon mal eine viel, viel bessere Situation als vor drei Jahren, als wir da kein Gesetz in Europa hatten zu dem Thema,
überhaupt kein Werkzeugkasten, um sowas wie ein Spotify-Deal vielleicht wegzubekommen oder irgendein beliebiges Blockieren, wo die deutsche Telekom sagt, nein, Walb, Immobilienfunk verbieten wir euch.
Und liss mir da nochmal kurz was eigentlich so die umstrittenen,
Punkte war. Also im im in der politischen Auseinandersetzung
war ja vor allem dieser Begriff der äh Specialise Services äh so ein ein sehr umstrittener Punkt, über den halt sozusagen Dienste von anderen unterschieden werden sollten, was ja, sagen wir mal, gerade im Hinblick auf,
Neutralität der Dienste im im Netz, was ja die Netzneutralität letztlich beschreibt. Äh das sozusagen im Widerspruch äh stand
und das Zero-Rating, was du gerade schon angesprochen hast, äh diese Praxis, äh Verträge anzubieten und zu sagen, na ja, wenn du hier bei uns dieses Telekom-Paket äh kaufst, dann sind bestimmte Dienste, Anbieter, äh,
los oder zu irgendeinem Flitre-Tarif zumindest äh darin enthalten. Ähm,
Also was siehst du denn jetzt sozusagen bei der was waren, was waren denn sozusagen die die Punkte in der in der verabschiedeten Verordnung, die jetzt hätten auch,
Schlecht ausfallen können, wo ihr euch jetzt sozusagen auch direkt drangesetzt habt.
Also es gibt drei große Themen über die verhandelt wurde ähm für jedes dieser Themen gab's auch eine eigene Arbeitsgruppe innerhalb von Berek, also so nochmal alle Ökonomen, die über Serating verhandelt haben, alle Techniker, die über Verkehrsmanagement
verhandelt haben und die Spezialdienste, das sind die drei Themen, über die wir sprechen müssen. Und bei den Spezialdiensten,
haben wir es wirklich geschafft ähm einen Sieg auf ganzer Linie zu erinnern.
Mit den jetzt verabschiedeten Text sind die zwei gefahren, um die gestritten wurde gebahnt, nämlich einerseits,
Das ist ein Spezialdienst ist ja eigentlich eine bezahlte Überholspur im klassischen Sinne. Da bekommt ein Internetprovider Geld von einem Inhalteanbieter,
wie Google oder BMW und dafür behandelt er diesen diesen Dienst von diesem Anbieter an, ja? Es gibt ihm einen technischen Vorteil, überträgt ihn schneller,
meistens ist er dann auch geseurated, weil er nicht Teil des Internets ist.
Also Spezialdienste haben so es gibt zwei Bedeutungen von diesem Wort. Äh ursprünglich kommt das eigentlich daher, dass man sagt.
Ist speziell, weil er nichts mit dem Internet zu tun hat.
Weil er vielleicht übers Internet gar nicht funktionieren kann technisch und weil er auch Anforderungen hat, die man im Internet nicht realisieren kann.
Leider gab's dann eben auch so die Interpretation von Weiten wie Günther Oettinger, ähm, der Digitalkommissar der Herzen, der meint, ja, aber das muss allen zur Verfügung stehen und.
Telekom hat ja immer wieder gedrängt darauf, dass sie Spezialdienste auch an Startups anbie.
Genau diese Gefahr, dass ich an einem bestehenden Dienst aus dem Internet auf die Überholspur eines Spezialdienstes hebe,
diese Gefahr ist gebahnt, so eine Regassifizierung kann es eigentlich nicht geben, weil der Text da sehr eindeutig ist und die Regulierungsbehörden an der Stelle fast keinen Spielraum haben, äh solche Dinge zu erlauben.
Okay, aber äh was hat denn die Verordnung gesagt? Was war denn die Formulierung äh die jetzt der Konkretisierung bedurfte.
Also da ähm war in einem der Bewegungsgründe, also der Erklärungen des Gesetzes.
Komische Formulierung drinnen, also es heißt, dass so ein Spezialdienst nur dann angeboten werden darf, wenn ähm,
Optimierung objektiv notwendig ist. Um die Qualitätsanforderungen von dem Inhalt, der da übertragen wird, genüge zu tun,
und dem User die Zusicherung zu machen, dass er auch wirklich diese,
Qualität dieses Qualitätslevel bekommt. Und worüber wir ganz viel bestritten haben und im bei dem letzten Text jetzt, bei deinen letzten Änderungen noch gewonnen haben, ist zum Beispiel ähm dass hier wirklich eine technische Prüfung passieren muss, dass es wirklich objektiv notwendig sein muss,
zum Beispiel ich nicht einfach ähm,
Skype Ultra HD anbieten kann und das steht in den AGBs, das ist äh immer Crystal Clear und immer höchste Sprachqualität und deswegen ist es ein Spezialdienst,
sondern nein, das muss wirklich technisch geboten sein in diesem Dienst. Und ich kann da auch keine kleine Varianz machen, zum Beispiel, dass die Sta,
variablen Bittrate, die anpassungsfähig ist, wenn die Leitung jetzt mal dicker oder dünner ist,
immer Voraussetzer, dass ich eine konstante Betreat fahren kann und einfach immer meine Internetleitung eine gewisse Dicke nicht unterschreiten,
Über solche Details wurde da gestritten?
Sind sehr technisch, aber die machen dann sehr viel aus, weil da entscheidet sich dann eben, ob ähm die Internetdienste weiter auf Augenhöhe unterwegs sind oder ob manche sich eben einen Vorteil kaufen können.
Also was würde also Objektivierung notwendig, technische Prüfung, kannst du mal ein Beispiel geben für für etwas, was diesen Anforderungen jetzt entspräche, also was,
ist denn sozusagen mit dem, was die Bereg jetzt definiert als Spezialdienst äh möglich.
Ich finde das immer so toll, wenn mir die Leute solche Fragen stellen, ähm weil ähm.
Als die Kommission dieses Gesetz in Auftrag gegeben hat, vorgestellt hat, haben sie einfach reingeschrieben, wir brauchen das. Auch jetzt stehen Gesetz drinnen. Es gibt Bedarf an solchen Spezialdiensten.
Wirkliche konkrete Beispiele, wo ein Dienst heute im Internet nicht möglich ist und der wirklich so nur eine Sonderbehandlung braucht,
gibt's meiner Meinung nach ganz wenige, ja? Also.
Sicher selbst fahrende Autos könnte man dazu zählen, wobei das wären ja ferngesteuerte Autos. Ein selbstfahrendes Auto kann auch mal durch ein Funkloch oder ein Tunkel fahren und fährt weiter.
Und deswegen das ist ein Großteils einer Scheindebatte,
wie gesagt, wenn man, wenn man mal zurückschaut, Berek hat sich schon zweitausendzwölf mit dem Thema Spezialdienste beschäftigt und sehr kluge Dinge dazu geschrieben,
vom Gesetzgeber nicht aufgegriffen wurden, also uns war immer klar, die wir in der Debatte sind, worum es dabei geht,
Aber es ist hier wirklich nicht so, als wenn die Wirtschaft äh mit den Hufen schadet, weil sie keine Spezialdienste haben können. Ähm deswegen,
dort wo es wirklich notwendig möglich ist solche Dinge zu machen, wo sie innovativ sind und dem Internet nicht im Wege stehen, eben auch keine Bandbreite abzwicken. Da kann man jetzt solche Spezialdienste anbieten, aber es ist eben,
sehr abgesichert, dass ich einen normalen Internetdienst auf einmal auf der Überholsp.
Wodurch es denn das jetzt konkret äh abgesichert, also was was ist was für eine Formulierung ist denn da jetzt gewählt worden, wo du meinst, da geht jetzt nichts mehr dran vorbei.
Also da war der Draft, der Guideline schon recht gut, habe ich auch in einer meiner ersten Analysen davon, als der,
Anfang Juni raus kam auf Netzpolitik Orke so geschrieben und jetzt wurde aber nochmal nachgeschärft dadurch, dass man an den Stellen, wo es unklar formuliert war, wo es zum Beispiel so ausgeschauen hat,
als ob ähm der Internetprovider oder der Dienst der Anbieter selber einfach bestimmen können, wie diese Qualitätsanforderungen ausschauen,
dieser Text ist rausgeflogen oder da wo es so aussieht als würde einfach dadurch, dass ich in die AGBs reinschreibe,
ich hab neunundneunzig Komma neun neun Prozent äh zugesicherte Qualität, dass auch das auf einmal schon die objektive Qualität dieses Dienstes. Da ist auch nachgebessert worden,
also gerade an den Punkten wo ich als gefinkelter Telekom äh Jurist hergegangen wäre, um das da reinzuboxen. Da haben wir jetzt nochmal extra Safe Platz bekommen,
deswegen können wir sagen, dass ihn genau da, wo alle Experten gesagt haben, hier Finger auf die Wunde legen, da habt ihr noch ein Problem. Genau da wurde auch nachgeschärf.
Was für Safe Guards sind das jetzt? Also was ist was steht da konkret drin, dass äh dass man jetzt diese Schlüsse ziehen kann.
Eben wie ich beschrieben hab, also du hast im Gesetzestext diese objektive Prüfung, die der Regulierungsbehörde obliegt und dann hast du im Text ursprünglich aber Passagen gehabt, die sagen, okay, aber es kann auch,
jemand anderer diese Vorgaben machen und es kann auch über die AGBs äh oder oder Zusicherungen an den User solche Qualitätsanforderungen geben. Und das ist alles rausgeflogen, dadurch, dass es jetzt wirklich eine,
objektive notwendige technische Prüfung braucht, ähm die von der Regulierungsbehörde umgesetzt.
Wenn man diesen Text so liest und auch die Beispiele, die Berg nennt, ähm das ist zum Beispiel,
Voiceover LTE und äh Linea Broadcast.
Kommt schon sehr klar rüber, dass es zum Beispiel nicht Voiceover IP ist, äh, irgendein Skype oder Studiolink, wie wir das gerade verwenden,
und das ist eben wirklich nur klassisches IPTV sein kann im Sinne von ähm das, was früher eben auch Facility Base Fernsehen war, was über das Kabel kam, aber eben nicht Netflix, nicht online,
nicht diese Dienste, äh, wie wir sie eher im Internet kennen. Das heißt, da ist schon sehr klar angelegt, in welche Richtung es geht und dieser Text ist ja auch Ausdruck von einem Konsens, den die Regulierungsbehörden befunden haben.
Natürlich muss man sagen, es wird im Einzelfall entschieden,
alle diese Regeln die jetzt hier auch von mir gelobt werden dann von einunddreißig Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden die sich alle um ihr Land kümmern, umgesetzt im Einzelfall und im äh Expostfall, das heißt im Nachhinein,
bis auf wenige Länder ist es so, dass immer zuerst der Provider ein Produkt an den Start bringt und dann kann die Telekom-Behörde tätig werden und das im Zweifelsfall verbieten,
und da kommen wir eigentlich zum Punkt, den ich am Ende sagen wollte, wir müssen hier natürlich noch wachsam bleiben. Es ist ein Werkzeugkasten, der uns erlaubt, Netzneutralität in Europa durchzusetzen, wenn die Regulierungsbehörden ihren Job machen, dann müssen wir gar nichts dafür tun,
aber in den Ländern, wo die Regulierer sehr nahe an der Industrie sind, braucht das sicherlich auch nochmal eine kritische Öffentlichkeit,
Konsumentenschützer und netzpolitische NGOs, die genau hinschauen. Aber das ist auch eine Aufgabe, die wo wir nicht untätig bleiben werden.
Ja. Na gut, ich meine das heißt, was was so rein vom Gesetzestext her gibt es sozusagen diese Spezialdienste noch.
Nur die Anforderungen dafür sind sehr hoch.
Und äh wir wir werden es also vielleicht trotzdem noch sehen, dass jetzt irgendein Provider der Meinung ist, ja hier geiler Dienst ähm.
Mal vielleicht mal irgendwas raus. Ich meine, was was ist denn mit solchen Angeboten wie Fernsehstreaming und so weiter, so. Ja,
äh gibt's ja diese IP TV Geschichte von der Telekom, wo du dann quasi so deine dein dein dein Fußballstream äh so auf der letzten Meile äh bekommst.
Ähm ist das dann schon ein Spezialdienst, der sozusagen diese Sonderbehandlung ermöglicht oder ähm muss das.
Gutes Beispiel war zum.
Andere Sachen reingefaltet werden.
Gutes Beispiel wäre zum Beispiel ähm Multicast Fernsehen. Das äh weil einfach im normalen Internet ist ähm nicht ohne weiteres möglich ist an äh Multicass-Dienst anzubieten.
Das Spezialdienst kann ich diese Dinge durchaus machen. Ähm und da ist zum Beispiel so eine technische Anforderung gegeben.
Und ich ich will da gar nicht so viel spekulieren was jetzt alles kommen könnte oder nicht, weil wie gesagt wir debattieren seit drei Jahren darum.
In jeder Situation, die ich hatte mit Industrieleuten auf dem Panel zu sitzen oder auch mit Politikern und mit Günther Ettinger selbst.
Ich den einmal fünf Minuten getroffen hab gefragt was denn diese konkreten Beispiele sind das Set hat's niemand versucht niemand konnte konkrete Antworten geben.
Was wir jetzt getan haben ist, dass das möglichst abzusichern, dass hier nichts passieren kann, aber,
ich glaub wir werden in den nächsten Jahren mehr in dem Bereich sehen, ich vertraue aber auch darauf,
die Telekomindustrie jetzt nicht die tollen innovativen Dienste brennen wird, vor allem auch, weil ähm wir diese Reklassifizierung einerseits als Sicherheitsstufe haben,
dann ist es aber auch so, dass es sicherheits äh Safecards gibt bezüglich der Bandbreite. Also ich muss zum Beispiel fast immer neue Bandbreite zur Verfügung stellen, um einen Spezialdienst anzu.
Kann bis auf wenige Fälle jetzt nicht hergehen und sagen, ich reduziere die Bandbreite für das normale Internet,
sondern da muss auch wirklich sozusagen in der Infrastruktur zumindest in der logischen Kapazität etwas getan werden, damit zusätzliche Ressourcen zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Für diese anderen Zugangsdienste.
Aber wie kann man sowas denn äh beweisen? Also ich meine,
ja hier auch diesen diesen Fall, dass dass die, dass die Telekom in Deutschland ja teilweise mit manchen Anbietern halt auch nicht ausreichend vernetzt ist, so, ja, dass da irgendwie auch gar nicht genug Daten rüberkommen und das ist ja allein dadurch schon,
schwierig ist, die entsprechenden Bandbreiten zu erzielen.
Ja, der ganze Bereich Interconnection, den du ansprichst, da wo ähm schon weiter ihre Netze zusammenschalten.
Da gibt es das ist nicht unmittelbar Teil der Verordnung und jetzt der Regulierung,
Es gibt aber einen Passus, der sagt, dass da, wo das Recht, wir haben nämlich auch ein neues Recht bekommen als Nutzer, dass wir auf Informationen und Dienst zugreifen dürfen und auch diese anbieten dürfen,
wo der die Interconnection so schlecht ist, dass dieses Recht unterwandert wird, hat die Regulierungsbehörde auch die Möglichkeit tätig zu werden. Also das ist ähnlich wie in den ähm USA,
bei den Regeln der FC so ein weiches Kriterium, wo ich wo es dann nicht unmittelbaren Prüfauftrag gibt, aber wenn's Missstände gibt, kann man hier durchaus tätig werden.
Aber so an sich der Bereich Interconnection ist auch einer, der sehr intransparent ist, wo es ganz wenig Daten darüber gibt.
Wie der Markt funktioniert, wo die Missstände liegen und deswegen ist es auch schwierig da ähm eine gesetzliche Regelung zu formulieren, die die Probleme löst, die man.
Aber das ist aber nochmal ein ganz neues Fass, was hier aufgemacht werden muss und was jetzt vielleicht so in der nahen Zukunft ansteht, aber was jetzt mit der unmittelbaren Umsetzung der Netzneutralitätsverordnung so nichts zu tun hat.
Aber um deine Folgefrage zu beantworten, also ähm wie wird das alles dann umgesetzt.
Natürlich wird der ganze Bereich des des Messens von Internetressourcen und Bandbreiten hier nochmal wichtiger.
Hier sind die Regulierungsbehörden eh schon dabei, solche Testtools zur Verfügung zu stellen, die sind auch zum überwiegenden Teil aller Open Source, ähm, verfolgen nochmal dazu, das Prinzip Open Data, also man kann wirklich.
Datenbasis genau äh unabhängig analysieren und seine eigenen Interpretationen von dem Datenmaterial machen.
Weil man da erkannt hat, das ist so ein Problem, wo man sich mehr bewusst werden muss. Wo gibt's vielleicht schleichende Verschlechterungen der Internetqualität, weil Provider versuchen langsam,
verfügbaren Leitungen in Richtung Spezialdienste wandern zu lassen.
Das heißt das ist ein Thema wo die auch die Netzwerk-Community sicherlich wachsam bleiben muss noch mehr als sonst in Europa.
Wo es aber auch, wenn Regulierungsbehörden eben wirklich das Ernst meinen,
ganz starke Bestimmungen gibt, dass die in jedem Interview weiter reinschauen dürfen, also dienen muss Auskunft gegeben werden wie ein Netzwerk konkret konfiguriert ist, auch welches Verkehrsmanagement,
dort vorherrscht und wann genau das greift, mit welchen Absichten diese Regeln äh konfiguriert sind.
Und dadurch gibt's schon auch äh im Einzelfall eine große Möglichkeit tätig zu werden für die Regionsbehörde und zuletzt die Strafen sind auch ähm.
In manchen Ländern sehr empfindlich, also in den Niederlanden sind's ähm glaube ich vierhundertfünfzigtausend Euro oder zehn Prozent des Konzernumsatzes, was höher ist als Maximum,
In Deutschland sind's glaube ich nur so um die fünfhunderttausend äh Strafe, was für die deutsche Telekom jetzt sicherlich nicht zu viel ist.
Aber das wird national entschieden. Also die, wie viel ich zahlen muss, wenn ich gegen Netzentralität verstoße, es leider auf Länderebene und nicht auf EU-Ebene entschieden worden,
Bei der Datenschutzgrundverordnung hat man das gleich ins EU-Gesetz reingeschrieben, dass es sehr hohe Strafen gibt und dadurch ist der Abschreckungseffekt natürlich um einiges größer,
weil am Ende unterhalten sich Unternehmen immer nur an Dinge, die in Geld kostenpotential.
War denn das jetzt sozusagen auch eine eine Entscheidung der Berek das so zu machen oder hat das schon die Verordnung vorgegeben.
Dass die Vorordnung schon vorgegeben.
Okay, gut, also da war jetzt gar kein äh Gestaltungsspielraum. Also grundsätzlich ist es so.
Telekommunikationsunternehmen könnte nach wie vor auf die Idee kommen irgendwelche Spezialdienste, Sonderregelungen oder andere äh Trimmer einzusetzen, dann allerdings kann man über die,
Über die nationale Regulierungsbehörde, also in Deutschland dann mit der Rick TP dagegen vorgehen oder ist es etwas, was auch über die Berik läuft.
Das geht immer über die nationale Schiene, also Berek ist ähm wirklich nur, das kann man sich für einen dünnen Schirm vorstellen über den,
nationalen Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden, aber ich muss national zu der äh Behörde gehen und mich dort beschweren. Da müssen die auch tätig werden,
Deutschland eben die Bundesnetzagentur.
Und ähm wir arbeiten auch dran, vielleicht diesen Prozess zu vereinfachen und noch User freundlicher zu machen, aber denen einfach eine E-Mail schicken äh oder mal anrufen und sagen, hier dieser und jener Fall ist das eine Rezentralitätsverletzung, äh könnt ihr das prüfen.
Hat man jetzt halt eben, um da drauf zuzugehen,
wir werden was man auch machen kann auf Respekt manet äh Punkt EU kann man auch solche Fälle melden. Wir prüfen die dann und äh schauen eben auch, wie wir dann,
dafür sorgen, dass es 'ne einheitliche Umsetzung gibt. Also einerseits, wir wollen informiert bleiben, was passiert jetzt in den einunddreißig Ländern, für die dieses neue Netzwerksgesetz gilt.
Wie entwickelt sich der Markt, welche Spezialdienste werden ausprobiert, welches wird ausprobiert und wie agieren die einzelnen nationalen Regulierungsbehörden dazu.
Und da muss man sicherlich auf die Einhaltung brauchen. Also es gibt viele Länder, wo ich sage mal die Unabhängigkeit dieser Behörde eher nur auf dem Papier existiert,
da muss man genauer hinschauen, aber äh ich bin wirklich der Meinung, dass wir mit diesem Gesetz einen sehr guten Werkzeugkasten haben, um am Ende der Netzautalität in ganz Europa umzugehen.
Mhm. Was ja ein bisschen
zu sein, schien jetzt in der ersten Reaktion auf diese Nachricht, also wir es ist ja alles noch relativ frisch, ich hab bisher eigentlich nur Interpretationen gelesen, ich hab doch noch nirgendswo das Originaldokument
gesehen ist das überhaupt schon veröffentlicht worden.
Ja ja sofort während der Pressekonferenz am Dienstag ist seit vierzehn Uhr dreißig online verlinken wir auch.
Ah okay, ja genau, gib mir mal einen Link. Ich habe das bisher noch nicht gesehen. Äh was ja dann in der Debatte schnell aufstieg, war ja äh der Punkt des Zero Ratings. Was,
Also siehst du das äh als gerechtfertigt an, dass da noch Einschränkungen gibt, was was steckt dahinter hinter dieser Reaktion?
Also ähm wo kommen wir daher? Also Zero Rating ist sicherlich der Bereich, wo das Gesetz am schwammigsten formuliert ist.
Und wir haben ganz viel darum gestritten, dass also im Originalen Entwurf, der in die Konsultation ging, hat Bere gesagt,
Das ist alles eine Einzelfallprüfung, also über jedes einzelne Angebot entscheidet jede Regulierungsbehörde im Einzelfall. Das sind die Kriterien, nach denen hier geprüft werden muss,
aber es gibt keine pauschale Schwarz-Weiß-Regelung, das ist verboten und das ist erlaubt.
Da haben wir ganz stark gekämpft dafür, dass das nochmal geändert wird und leider verloren,
Es gibt hier keine klare Regelung, dass zum Beispiel ähm Cirating, wo nur einzelne Dienste, wie zum Beispiel Spotify, vom Datenvolumen ausgenommen werden oder Serratings, wo,
Inhalte Anbieter wie Google wie Facebook zahlen dafür, dass ihre Daten ausgenommen sind aus dem Volumen der Kunden, dass zumindest diese ganz schlimmen Formen verboten sind.
Ich glaub dass das die Verordnung durchaus hergegeben hätte. Ich hoffe auch, dass wir mal die Möglichkeit bekommen das vor Gericht durchzustreiten,
Ich bin der Geschäftsführer vom Ackervorrat, das mit klagen können wir und ich hoffe, dass wir das irgendwann mal vor den EuGH brennen, weil ich glaube, das Gesetz würde so eine Verbot zulassen.
Aber jetzt ist im finalen Text leider hier die Einzelfalletscheidung so geblieben wie sie vorher war,
das heißt jede Regulierungsbehörde kann jedem Serating Deal für sich betrachten,
das kam dann vielleicht sogar zu der Situation führen, dass dasselbe Spotify-Angebot in dem einen Land erlaubt und im anderen verboten.
Das ist natürlich dann kein Binnenmarkt. Das Ganze ist ja unter dem Titel Digital Single Marke, Telekom Winnemarkt, den wollte man hier erreichen. Da hat man das Ziel erwach,
fehlt. Ähm und wie in den USA geben die Netzzentralitätsregeln in Europa hier eben leider nicht mehr her,
Es ist nur klargestellt, dass es gewisse unstrittige Formen von äh Zero Rating gibt, zum Beispiel wenn ein Internetprovider.
Ähm die da zum Beispiel in den Nachtstunden so zwischen Mitternacht und vier Uhr früh äh rechne ich dir dann einen Datenverbrauch nicht auf dein monatliches Volumen an,
dass wir auch eine Form von Sero Rating, die aus Netzen, Qualitätsperspektive unkritisch ist, weil der wird ja nicht zwischen einzelnen Diensten entschieden,
Du hast heute einfach einen eine Flagtrade für die vier Stunden, wo sonst keiner im Internet ist. Da wird niemand bevorzugt oder benachteiligt, die Form von Serating ist klar erlaubt.
Klar erlaubt ist auch Sero Rating von äh Customer Service Portos. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel ähm auf die Website meines Mobilfunkes gehen will und dort mehr Datenvolumen kaufen, obwohl ich eigentlich gar keines mehr habe.
Dann fällt das auch nicht in mein Volumen rein.
Und das sind eigentlich recht gute Ausnahmen, aber auf der Gegenseite, dass ich wenigstens, wenn ich die Guten erlaube und auch die Schlechten, die eindeutig schlechten verbiete, das äh ist eben daran nicht möglich gewesen in dem T.
Also die von dir schon genannten Spotify-Angebote, die haben wir ja in Deutschland zum Beispiel, sicherlich auch ein paar anderen Ländern, gibt's denn schon irgendwelche Länder, die da eher so eine Position einnehmen, dass sie sowas nicht erlauben würden.
Also ähm kurzer Hinweis noch, die deutsche Telekom hat das Spotify-Angebot kürzlich.
Aufgehoben, also für Neukunden gibt's kein Zerating von Spotify mehr, deutsche Telekom hat das eingestellt, was ich sehr spannend finde, weil es ist eigentlich nicht ihre offizielle Position.
Aber ja in vielen Ländern gibt es solche diostischen Mobilfunkern und Musikstreaminganbietern und meistens sind die auch gegenseitig exklusiv und das heißt eine sehr starke Einschränkung der Wahlfreiheit der Kunden.
Ähm bis jetzt hat sich doch keine Regulierungsbehörde dazu geäußert. Ähm es gibt aber in äh in Österreich äh seit,
gestern, also an dem Tag nachdem die Regeln vorgestellt wurden, gab's auch ein neues Zerating-Angebot.
Wo die größten Boulevardmedien in Österreich äh jetzt als Mobilfunker auftreten mit eigenen Tarifen, in denen sie ihre eigenen Zeitungsportale zerraten.
Die Media Print, das ist das Equivalent zum Axel Springer Verlag in Österreich und die Kronenzeitung ist auch so ungefähr genauso schlimm wie die Bild.
Die fangen jetzt auch an mit Netzautalitätsverletzungen. Also wir haben gleich einen sehr schönen prominenten Fall in Österreich, auf den ich mich schon freue, weil ähm da können wir auch gleich dafür sorgen, dass diese neuen Regeln ordentlich umgese.
Aber letzten Endes hängt's, aber es hängt ja letzten Endes dann davon ab, wie sich die nationale Regierungs äh Regelung Regulierungsbehörde dazu verhält. Hast du da irgendwelche Einblicke, wie die das so sieht.
Also jetzt in den zwei Tagen seid ihr Regeln vorgestellt worden hat sich glaube ich noch keine Regulierungsbehörde,
gerührt dazu auf der Pressekonferenz in Brüssel am Dienstag war so das,
man das eher auch als Erfolg gefeiert hat, dass man eben diesen guten Kompromiss gefunden hat.
Aber da waren die Leute auch mit ihrem Beere gut dort und jetzt nicht mit ihrem nationalen Hut. Also auch die Vertreter der Bundesnetzagentur äh Deutschland hat ja gerade den Vorsitz auf äh EU-Ebene innerhalb der Bera,
hat man jetzt nichts durchblicken lassen wo der erste Einsatzfall dieser neuen Regeln ist. Das hängt aber auch sicherlich ganz stark davon ab, wie sich jetzt die Telefonbranche verhält.
Ob man nicht so traditioniert jetzt einhält oder erst recht austestet, was alles geht.
Und dann am Ende natürlich auch ähm die Zivilgesellschaften, die Konsumentenschützer ähm wie gut wir daran sind, diese Regeln einzufordern. Ähm, wie gesagt, das Handhabzeug haben wir jetzt, ähm wir müssen's halt nur einsetzen.
Und ich glaube, gerade im Zero Rating ähm wird spannend bleiben, weil's halt wirklich alles nur in Einzelfallentscheidungen gefällt werden wird. Das heißt, das bleibt spannend, so wie in den USA auch.
Aber wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe, äh wäre das ja im Prinzip dann ein schneller Präzedenzfall, so Spotify hier erlaubt, Spotify in dem anderen Land nicht erlaubt. Da müsste er dann wirklich eigentlich der EuGH sofort tätig werden.
OGH kommt man nicht zu schnell, da musst du zuerst irgendwie über die genau nach oben.
Klagen. Ich weiß aber man könnte das halt äh dahin eskalieren, indem man sozusagen erstmal in einem Land dagegen vorgeht.
Das ist sicherlich eine spannende Variante wo wir auch sehr dankbar sind, wenn irgendjemand da klagen will, vor allem wenn,
äh man vielleicht eine Firma oder ähm ein Nachrichtenportal hat, das konkuriert mit einem Gesirritten Angebot. Daraus könnte man sehr klaren äh juristischen Fall ableiten.
Ansonsten gibt's noch immer die nicht Hebel, wenn diese Regeln jetzt nicht zu einem einheitlichen Markt führen, weil wirklich alle Regulierungsbehörden ganz anders entscheiden,
es gibt Reviewklausen, sowohl in den Guidelands, die jetzt verabschiedet wurden, wie auch in dem ursprünglichen Gesetz,
überall da, wo es äh eine fragmentierte Situation gibt,
haben wir auch ein gutes Argument gegenüber und gegenüber der EU-Kommission hier nachzuschärfen und dann eben auch das Gesetz zu reparieren, dass es zu dieser einheitlichen Regelung kommt.
Auf EU-Ebene jetzt oder auf Bereg Ebene.
Je nachdem die Guidelines können reviewed werden, wenn Berit glaubt, es ist an der Zeit,
das Gesetz kann natürlich auch reviewed werden, wobei da muss man dazu sagen, Verordnungen auf EU-Ebene haben eigentlich eine sehr lange Lebensdauer, aber ähm.
Ist nicht berechenbar, das heißt, man könnte hier auch annehmen, dass die Kommission glaubt, sie muss was verschlechtern und dann schaffen wir es, wie bei diesem Gesetz, dass wir am Ende eine Verbesserung draus mach.
Und der letzte Fall, wie man das Ganze vor dem AGA bringen kann oder nochmal ändern kann,
in den Niederlanden gibt es ein Gesetz, das Zero Rating explizit verbietet und das ist jetzt nach dieser EU-Verordnung verabschiedet worden. Also die Niederländer haben sich angeschaut, was so für U-Ebene rauskam,
obwohl das eine Verordnung ist, die eigentlich äh kein nationales Gesetz braucht, haben sie gesagt, na wir konkretisieren das mal,
die haben eben genau das getan, was wir uns gewünscht haben, was auch die Inder gemacht haben, nämlich alle schlechten Formeln von Zero Rating äh verboten.
Das ist ein sehr mutiger Schritt in die Niederlanden gewesen,
Jetzt muss man sehen, ähm ob gegen dieses Gesetz geklagt wird, von einem niederländischen Telekom-Betreiber oder ob die EU-Kommission nicht vielleicht sogar in Vertragsverletzungsverfahren einleitet,
das habe ich auch dem Vertreter der EU-Kommission gefragt, ob sie das vorhaben. Da hat er sich leider nicht in die Karten blicken lassen, aber das wäre nochmal so ein Hebel, wie man das dann auch recht schnell ähm nochmal vor Gericht prüfen lassen kann.
Mhm. Und wer das Bestand hat, dann wäre er im Prinzip jegliche wäre ja im Prinzip jeglicher Fall von Zero-Rating automatisch äh anklagbar im Vergleich zu der Situation in Holland.
Hat zumindest meinen wertvollen Präsidenzfall geschaffen, dass diese Interpretation des Gesetzes auch von höchstgerichtlicher Seite okay ist ähm und dass man damit halt viel mehr Spielraum hat als Erik sich das jetzt erlaubt hat.
Und das hilft auf jeden Fall ungemein in den darauffolgenden Kämpfen,
das Problem mit Originalentscheidungen ist immer, wie weit man die dann sofort auch national verwerten kann. Siehe Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Das heißt eigentlich der das schärfste äh Schwert wäre eigentlich tatsächlich eine Neuentscheidung der Berik. Inwiefern darf denn die Berik jetzt ohne weiteres,
die jetzt verabschiedeten Sachen neu fassen.
Mehr oder weniger keine Einschränkungen. Nee, also es es gibt eine Möglichkeit, es gibt einen Review-Klausel, die sehr breit gefasst ist,
und die besagt, dass man sozusagen, wenn's an der Zeit ist, wenn die Notwendigkeit entsteht, dann kann man ähm diese Regeln auch äh neu schreiben. Und man soll auch die ganze Zeit im Austausch stehen mit allen Stilkoldern und Zivilgesellschaft.
Ich ich sehe jetzt eher.
Die eine ganz wichtige Zeit, in der wir die Debatte führen müssen mit den Regulierungsbehörden sozusagen. Wir müssen genau beobachten, welche Verletzungen der Netzeutralität gibt es in Europa,
wo können wir mit den neuen Regeln dagegen argumentieren und wenn wir diese Argumente sinnvoll vortragen,
glaub ich können wir die Behörden schon mit dem Text der jetzt am Tierschlüpf dazu bringen dass wir in der Zentrale Theke praktisch im Markt im Internet bekommen.
Das Problem wird eines sein, wo wir optisch eine Sprachbarriere, weil versuchen wir irgendwie die Tarifbestimmungen ähm in Slowenien, in Italien,
sinnvoll zu verstehen, vor allem wie sich die entwickeln und dann in diesen Ländern tätig zu werden. Also Idri ist damit noch wichtiger geworden, weil wir halt wirklich ein europäisches Netzwerk von Organisationen brauchen,
diese Koalition, die wir mit Safety Internet über die drei Jahre aufgebaut haben mit den zweiunddreißig NGOs aus ganz Europa,
werden wir sicherlich weiterhin brauchen und die muss noch mehr wachsen, dass wir eben in den Ländern zumindest einen Partner haben, mit dem wir diese Dinge auch umsetzen können.
Also ich höre es schon raus, also du bist eigentlich jetzt sehr zufrieden mit mit dem Ergebnis.
Also sicher ist, es gibt immer noch graue Zonen, wo wo das hätte besser sein können, aber ich sage mal äh,
ich bin ja auch jemand, der mit diesen Regeln weiter arbeiten muss und ich glaube, wir haben hier wirklich ein gutes Handwerkszeug bekommen,
ich glaube einfach, dass wir in der Praxis mit diesen Regeln gewinnen können. Das ist der Grund, wieso ich positiv.
Also wenn man das vom Ende her denkt und ich glaube, man muss net so Qualität immer vom Ende her denken, was kommt dabei am Ende raus, dann ist das ein ähm ein gutes ähm Set an Regeln, mit denen wir leben können,
es ist sicherlich nicht alles, was wir, was wir gewollt haben, aber es ist ein riesiger Schritt nach vorne.
Und wir werden damit halt einfach ein viel neutraleres und viel gleichberechtigteres Internet haben als vorher.
Das war das Ziel, deswegen bin ich eigentlich zufrieden.
Jetzt ähm.
Hatten wir ja schon mal äh viel darüber gesprochen, wie er so auf EU-Ebene äh aktiv geworden seid. Wir äh mit der Edri und anderen Gruppen dort ähm,
Parlamentariern gesprochen habe, mit anderen Gruppen, mit Leuten wahrscheinlich auch aus der Kommission, also quasi allen Beteiligten,
War denn jetzt der dieser zweite Schritt, also die Auseinandersetzung mit äh dem Berik-Prozess,
irgendwie anders, gab's da war das wird es ein anderes Vorgehen für euch, musstet ihr euch da in irgendeiner Form anders aufstellen
mal so ein bisschen schildern wie die Einflussnahme jetzt organisiert war und ob sich das in irgendeiner Form von der Tätigkeit vorher unterschieden hat.
Weil man hat's ja jetzt mit einem anderen Body zu tun sozusagen. Das ist ja ein ein sehr viel. Ich unterstelle jetzt mal sehr viel technokratischerer äh Bereich, der äh.
Vielleicht normalerweise nicht so Politik getrieben ist, ist jetzt eine eine reine Vermutung von mir, vielleicht stimmt's auch gar nicht oder äh ist das genauso Politik wie, wie sonst auch.
Hm. Ähm es war schon auf jeden Schritt der Kampagne.
Sehr anderes Look empfehlen. Also am Anfang in in erster Lesung im Parlament hatten wir.
Hatten wir sehr gute Karten, weil das war vor der Wahl, das waren Abgeordnete, die wirklich.
Mit ihrem freien Mandat entscheiden und nicht unbedingt einer Partei folgen. Da hatten wir am meisten Spielraum, am meisten Gehör und haben uns auch am stärksten durchgesetzt.
Danach.
Der Rat war nochmal viel schlimmer als die Regulierungsbehörden. Da hat man keinen Ansprechpartner. Das sind irgendwelche Ministeriumsmitarbeiter, die überhaupt keine ähm nichts befürchten müssen, die dann jetzt die öffentliche Meinung egal, weil das macht ja eh die EU nicht.
In Trilog, da wo die drei Institutionen zusammengehen sah es schon sehr schwierig, weil das ist ein ganz kleines Team an Verhandlern.
Und,
jetzt eben in zweiter Lesung war's schon, war schon wieder ein bisschen leichter, aber ich sage mal, da haben wir auch viele, viele Abgeordnete erreicht, nur es gibt halt einfach ganz, ganz selten Änderungsanträge in zweiter Lesung äh im Europaparlament.
Und dann jetzt.
Wie wir in dieser Phase mit den Regulierungsbehörden begangen sind. Haben wir ein bisschen auch von den internationalen Erfahrungen profitiert. Also ich habe ganz viel Austausch gehabt.
Den Leuten, die in den USA dort die Netzzentralitätskampagne gemacht haben oder mit unseren Kollegen aus Indien oder Lateinamerika,
Deswegen waren die recht gut vorbereitet. Übrigens auch die andere Seite, also Berek hat ganz viel mit der FCC gesprochen,
von denen gelernt, wie sie jetzt mit diesem enormen Ansturm an öffentlichen Interesse und Kommentaren in ihrer Konsultation umgehen sollen.
So viel Aufmerksamkeit haben die noch nie gehabt, oder?
Noch nie, also die äh ich glaub zweiundsiebzig oder hundert Antworten auf eine Konsultation, was Maximum, was Beratung jemals bekommen hat.
Wir haben sie mit fünfhunderttausend bombardiert das war für sich sicherlich auch 'ne neue Erfahrung und ich,
finde das aber gut, wenn die Regulierungsbehörden merken, okay, da gibt's öffentliches Interesse für ihre Arbeit. Ähm das ist ein wirklich wichtiges Thema und nicht wie,
jetzt irgendwelches am Bandeling oder Rufnummernverordnungen oder solche Dinge, sondern da geht's wirklich um etwas, dass die Menschen wichtig ist, das hat sehr geholfen.
Und das war natürlich auch vor allem in einer kurzen Zeit eine enorme Herausforderung, weil das Gesetz hat ihnen nur neun Monate gegeben, um diese Guidelines zu veröffentlichen,
Das heißt, sie mussten mal irgendwie den Draft schreiben, untereinander sich einig werden,
dann so enorm viel Input aus der Öffentlichkeit annehmen und aus dem auch noch Sinn machen. Also da war sicherlich ähm.
Die größte Herausforderung äh einfach auch mit all dieser Datenmenge umzugehen und die sinnvoll zu passen.
Und ich glaube aber, dass sie gerade da auch einen guten Job gemacht haben. Also ich bin noch nicht ganz durch, es gibt doch ein Dokument, das werden wir auch verlinken,
wo die Konzentration ausgewertet wurde äh und alle Argumente sozusagen gegenübergestellt und erklärt, wieso Bered an der Stelle,
Argument gefolgt ist oder eben nicht.
Es werden auch die Antworten auf die Konzentration aller öffentlich gemacht, also da wird's auch ein riesigen Datenschatz geben, ähm den hoffentlich dann auch noch unabhängige Wissenschaftler analysieren werden in den USA gibt's da sehr tolle Ausarbeitungen.
Mhm. Okay. Ja.
Was bedeutet denn das jetzt sozusagen für dich? Also ich meine, du hast jetzt wie lange an dem ganzen Thema rumgeknuspert drei Jahre.
In dem ich bin immer noch so ein bisschen.
Am am am am Austesten, was das jetzt alles genau heißt, weil das war ein riesiger Brocken meines Lebens, dieses Ding drei Jahre lang wirklich so intensiv mitzuverfolgen.
Und ähm ich bin froh, dass das dass das alles geklappt hat. Ich hätte mir nie gedacht, dass wir so weit kommen.
Und ich freue mich auch einfach, weil da halt wirklich auch mal gezeigt wurde.
Zivilgesellschaft wirkt, Netzpolitik schafft es irgendwie Zukunft mitzugestalten und die die Ideen dieser Community und einer Netzphilosophie, die die können sich durchsetzen.
Und äh vor allem weil Netzautalität auch so ein Thema ist. Ich glaube, das kann man abhaken, das ist in unserer Generation lösbar. Datenschutz und Urheberrecht wird uns sowieso noch viel länger erhalten bleiben.
Äh ja hm.
Ich werde weiter irgendwie Telekoms machen, ähm freue mich aber auch irgendwie jetzt in Österreich mit der NGO hier vielleicht auch mal ein paar andere Themen zu machen.
Und ähm ja, das kommen die nächsten Kämpfe sowieso schon wieder auf uns zu, also Urheberrecht und.
Es gibt ganz viele andere EU-Gesetze, die in nächster Zeit auf uns zurollen.
Die Arbeit macht unheimlich viel Spaß und ich hoffe, dass auch irgendwie in dem Prozess alle die ihr Stück dazu beigetragen haben, sich auch freuen, dass dass es einfach was gebracht hat.
Und dass man jetzt irgendwie sehen kann und messen kann, ähm dass das Ergebnis besser ist als hätten die Leute sich nicht dafür interessieren.
Uns ich freue mich aber auch, wenn neue Leute dazu kommen. Also jetzt habe ich so dieses eine Ding intensiv begleitet und es braucht auch mal andere Leute, die irgendwie über eine Zentralität am Kongo sprechen oder die sich äh.
In die Materie reinwuseln und ähm ich bin noch nicht so weit wie andere Leute wie,
Sheramy Simum zum Beispiel äh ein Vorbild von mir, der in Rente gegangen ist, der ist jetzt ähm Aktivist im Ruhestand, soweit bin ich noch nicht, aber ich sehe schon, dass es ein Job ist,
man für ein paar Jahre gut machen kann und dann irgendwann muss man auch das den Staub weitergeben, so wie bei Lehrern, ich glaube auch nicht, dass man sein Leben lang ein guter Lehrer sein kann.
Ja. Äh wir hatten jetzt hier gerade in der letzten äh äh Sendung, als wir mit Markus und Matthias äh haben wir über die Datentöpfe der EU gesp
Wochen, sprich die ganzen neuen äh und alten Datenbanken zur Überwachung und Ein- und Auslasskontrolle, Strafverfolgung et cetera, die jetzt in zunehmendem Maße zusammengeführt werden sollen, die alte Leier, wir kennen das schon aus dem nationalen Prozessen und haben dann auch so ein wenig
das Problem gesehen, äh am Schluss, dass es einfach sehr schwierig ist äh da einen nennenswerten, aktivistischen ähm.
Widerstand zu erzeugen. Schlichtweil halt einerseits gut ist vielleicht jetzt auch nicht das Moost sexy äh äh Thema für manche vielleicht schon, aber das ist halt einfach so an einer europäischen Gegenöffentlichkeit,
Mangel, das einfach nicht genug ja Konsens erzielt werden kann über die Sprach und Kulturgrenzen hinweg,
Wie waren denn so deine Erfahrungen mit den Europäern, die sich quasi an eure Arbeit,
beteiligt haben. Also inwiefern kam es da äh zu so einem europäischen, gemeinsamen Handeln und fühlen dieser ganzen Sache.
Große Frage. Ähm nun ja, also.
Ich habe durch die Arbeit Europa auch viel besser kennengelernt äh oder zum ersten Mal so richtig kennengelernt. Also,
wenn man anderen Ländern auf Leute trifft, die ähnliche Dinge motivieren, die.
Ähnlich denken, aber dann vielleicht doch manche Dinge ganz anders machen, dann dann kann man da so viele Lehren daraus ziehen und ich glaub.
Einerseits wichtig diese Vielfalt in Europa mal zu kennen und wirklich auch in die Länder zu gehen und mit den Leuten dort ein gemeinsames Verständnis zu erzeugen, weil oft werden die Themen anders gesehen.
Netzneutralität, das ist ein, eine Debatte, die sie aus den USA getrieben wurde, da kommt sie her. Deswegen gibt's einen ähm einen stabileren Konsens über viele Dinge, auch weil.
Das Thema ja auch noch nicht so alt ist wie die wie die Datenschutz oder Überwachungsdebatte.
Ja oder Copy Reiter.
Genau und gleichzeitig aber auch äh weil wir ja doch hier einen großteils deutschsprachiges Publikum haben. Ähm äh ich sage mal.
Deutschland sich wirklich quer stellt bei Tieren oder in Deutschland eine Stimmung, hat ein Thema wirklich gut bearbeitet wird, dann hat das auch immer Abstrahleffekte.
Und deswegen ist es ähm auch wichtig, dass das vor allem die Netzpolitische Debatte in Deutschland sich nicht unterschätzt, in Österreich ist es anders. Wir sind so ein kleines Land, dass man viel leichter über den Tellerrand schaut.
Wir es allein sowieso nicht reißen werden, aber ich glaub in Deutschland kann man schon alleine viele Dinge viele schlechte Dinge verhindern, wenn man's ordentlich.
Ich glaub was was in der ganzen Überwachungsdebatte sowieso einer der großen Herausforderungen für uns sein wird ist.
Negativ auf positive Compadium umsteigen. Also das wir auch mal klar formulieren, was ist denn unsere Antwort auf diesen Überwachungswahn? Was sind unsere Gegenmodelle ähm und äh vielleicht auch für den Wert der Freiheit mal auf die Straße gehen.
Anstatt immer nur der den einzelnen Überwachungsgesetzen hinterher zu laufen. Also ich glaub den Kampf werden wir auf lange Sicht verlieren.
Muss man glaube ich ein bissel an der Strategie ändern. Ich glaub aber.
Der, der, das, das Bewusstsein bei den Leuten ist schon da, also ich glaube, viele Menschen haben inzwischen schon das Gefühl, dass es zu viel Überwachung gibt.
Das hat eher was mit Sensibilisierung zu tun und am Ende ist jede Kampagne sowieso erwachsenen Bildung, also jede Politik ist Erwachsenenbildung.
Und ich habe selbst gemerkt, wie es ist, so komplexe Themen, die niemandem was sagen in die breite Öffentlichkeit zu tragen, ist immer schwer,
man merkt auch schmerzlich die Fehler, wenn man das jetzt nicht wenn man nicht schafft es allen zu erklären aber das müssen wir halt als Anforderung an uns haben als Bewegung, dass wir breiten wirksamer werden, dass wir auch,
aus unserem Biotop und unserer Netzszene in der es gemütlich ist, nach außen treten und das einer ja, anderen Bevölkerungsschichten auch klar machen, wieso das wichtig.
Und ihnen zeigen, wie schön es bei uns ist, so eine Art digitaler Christopher Street Day, ja? Müssen wir jetzt irgendwie auch äh auf äh auf großen Trucks durch äh die Metropolen der Stadt äh ziehen.
Das für eine gute Idee.
Nacken tackend.
Ja mit WimCE. Gut.
Ja, sehr schön Thomas. Ähm
Ich weiß, der Aktivisto äh Aktivismus treibt dich äh auch schon wieder gleich ins äh nächste Meeting. Gibt's noch irgendein äh einen Aspekt, den ich jetzt so nicht hinterfragt habe, den du vielleicht noch gerne äh anbringen möchtest?
Ja, am Ende noch ein schönes Selfie-Plug, ähm der AK Vorrat, Arbeitskreisvorratsdaten freut sich über Spenden. Ähm die letzten Monate waren sehr zierend,
Aber wir wir als Organisation haben glaube ich sehr viel Arbeit darein gesteckt und auch sehr viele,
Stunden von unseren ehrenamtlichen und von unseren Mitarbeitern. Deswegen wär's toll, wenn Leute sich freuen über ähm das Ergebnis und ein paar Euro übrig haben. Man kann bei uns auch Fördermitglied werden.
Ähm und ansonsten.
Jetzt wurde sie alle fürs Spotify wieder voll bezahlen müssen. Kommst du mit sowas?
Ja, tut mir leid.
Aber dazu steigen die Datenvolumen ja verle.
Denke, das wird halt so ein, schon auch eine eine konkrete Auswirkung sein können, ne, dass äh dieser ganze äh Kampf um um um niedrige Bandbreiten, dass jetzt quasi die Anbieter jetzt mitziehen müssen und wenn sie Kunden gewinnen wollen, dann muss er halt irgendwie auch Snapchat und alles andere, was gerade hipp und,
angesagt ist, äh, drin sein und man kann sich eben nicht nur auf zwei, drei Dienste festlegen, also äh ich denke, die Diskussion darf man gar nicht erst in dieser Richtung äh äh führen, äh sondern im Prinzip,
müssen jetzt Provider einfach eine gute Dienstleistung anbringen und sich darüber
quasi ihre Freunde machen bei ihren Kunden und eben nicht über irgendwelche besonderen Deals, wo sie sich am Ende ja quasi den,
Breitbandausbau äh ausbauen, die vielleicht nicht haben, komplett sparen können, aber zumindest auf Sparflamme haben betreiben können. Ich denke, das war für viele äh lange Zeit eine Motivation und das geht halt jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, also zum wenn ich keine Überholspur verkaufen kann, ähm wenn ich alle Gleichbehandlung muss, dann habe ich auch keinen Grund, irgendwie mein eigenes Produkt zu verstümmeln und für künstliche Knappheit zu sorgen.
Und am Ende muss man die Provider ja auch davor retten, ihr eigenes Produkt kaputt zu machen, die müssen endlich.
Diese ganzen beliebten Internetdienste ihnen nichts wegnehmen, sondern äh eigentlich für die Nachfrage nach ihrem einzigen Produkt, nämlich bit sorgen.
Die Rolle mag ihnen nicht schmecken, die mag irgendwie gerade da, wo sie herkommen als alte Mobilfunker, die.
Terminierungsmonopolen äh sich ihrer Kundenbasis vergolden lassen konnten früher ähm die wollen dieses alte Modell,
und irgendwie die Zukunft ans Geschäftsmodell anpassen das wird halt nicht funktionieren, deshalb muss man hier.
Auch auch mal eine Debatte darüber führen, welchen Wert Internet als Infrastruktur.
Ob's nicht auch mal Zeit wäre für solche Modelle wie ähm strukturelle Trennung wie in Schweden zum Beispiel, das ist ja ähm bei der Freakshow schon öfter mit Clemens diskut.
Bin großer Anhänger dieses Modells. Äh wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass die Infrastruktur von den Internetzugangsanbietern getrennt wird auf lange Sicht,
das eine ist etwas, das wie Straße, Kanal wie Wasser, eine grundlegende gesellschaftliche Infrastruktur ist, die bitteschön im Glas zu sein hat,
Das andere, da kann der Markt passieren, da kann man Kunden eine Dienstleistung anbie.
Das wäre eigentlich der zukunftssichere Weg und da dahin müsste man gehen, damit könnte man auch im Mobilfunk mal anfangen oder eben auf lokaler Kommunenebene. Das kann ja jede Gemeinde auch für sich beginnen,
aber am Ende müssen wir auch dahin kommen,
das wir diesen den Charakter dieses Mediums und dieser Infrastruktur für unsere Gesellschaft gereicht werden.
Ja Thomas, dem kann ich jetzt wirklich nichts mehr hinzufügen, mache ich jetzt auch nicht. Äh ich bedanke mich äh für Adern der Arbeit und biete einen Beitrag hier für diese Sendung,
Ja und äh ich hoffe, du bist auch bald mal wieder äh bei uns zu Gast. Äh ich denke, wir sehen uns äh spätestens im äh.
So eine Party vom Netzpolitik äh Ork äh wieder, nicht wahr? Ich habe jetzt gerade das Datum nicht äh im Kopf, sonst hätte ich's Geschwinde raus.
Ganz genau zwölf Jahre Netzpolitik ist bald in Berlin.
Drüber oder sowas.
Siebter Oktober, du hast recht und die Privacy Week ist auch noch was, das man ankündigen kann, die ist vierundzwanzigster bis dreißigster Oktober in Wien, Privacy Week AT,
und netzpolitischer Abend ist heute Abend, aber das wird sich nicht ausgehen mit der Veröffentlichung, das.
Nee, das wird jetzt dann doch ein bisschen knapp.
Gut, danke Tim.
Okay, ich danke dir auch. Tschüss.
Tschüss.